at the top of the track right before a
race
i tell myself there's nothing i can't do
people have died doing this and i know
that but going 90 miles per hour is so
damn fun
my name is john daly and i'm a two-time
olympic skeleton slider
the skeleton track is roughly one mile
long and i'll slide up to 90 miles per
hour with my face only one inch off the
ice
you get a green light and you take off
sprinting and you can't hear a thing
when i make contact with the sled it
feels like a place i've been my whole
life
last 15 years i've made that same jump
onto the sled
you could feel immense pressure
as you're pulling five g's
so my eight pound head now weighs 40
pounds
[Music]
if you start to get stiff you start to
get scared
it's not gonna work the sled's gonna
break loose on you and you are gonna
crash you have to embrace the speed
instead of getting afraid of it
at the bottom of the skeleton race when
i've had a really good run i feel like i
could run through the wall you're so
pumped up and that's why i love it
[Music]
you